we've got a voicemail the voicemail
number is two one nine two david p i've
been getting hit hard over the last
couple of weeks for how i pronounce
things earlier this week I believe it
was maybe late last week a caller said
that I print a very cunning linguist
said that I pronounce the word new
incorrectly that it should be pronounced
only new not new and of course we looked
it up and both are accepted
pronunciations here is another voicemail
about how I have completely incorrectly
pronounced yet another word
hi David this is Anne calling from
Wisconsin right I just wanted to let you
know I enjoyed you a segment on Carl
Icahn and potentially insider trading
regarding the selling off of his stocks
in the Manitowoc company but I have to
admit I was a bit distracted by your
pronunciation of Manitowoc being a local
here I can tell you that the correct
pronunciation is not Manitowoc as you
were using but Manitowoc right Sam
Manitowoc company thought you might be
interested in hearing that or knowing
that anyways keeping the great work and
I very much look forward to your your
shows thank you David
bye-bye listen I don't mind this like I
have no problem being corrected on
pronunciations I mean in the end I can
always go back to English is my second
language and I'm doing the best I can
here to pronounce things I've been
corrected that it's not Nevada
it's Nevada it's not why it's or again
or oh that one I didn't know okay as of
30 seconds as if five seconds ago I've
been corrected on that one it's not
Hawaii its Hawaii
it is not Manitowoc it's the did she say
minute a walk I don't even remember this
city has a population of 33,000 people
that's legit just be glad that we're
mentioning them well I know it's like a
and it's not an insult
two-minute a walk it's it's not a place
that people nationally would necessarily
be aware of so I think it's
understandable that I might not
pronounce it correctly but I stand
corrected and I appreciate it and any
new Corrections that people want to send
in I'm glad to receive so thank you
we've got a great
so for you today we will talk about
what's going on in Texas with Democratic
voters we'll talk about protecting
immigrants in California we will talk
about the oldest message in a bottle
that has been found and much more get
access to the bonus show at david
pakman.com slash membership or at
patreon.com slash david pakman show